we have to convince amazon to bring back
stargate and well
we've got a plan
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
right i did a live video a couple of
weeks ago talking about how on july 27th
at 8pm here in the uk we are planning a
twitter storm we want to get as many
people that love stargate the same as we
do to jump on twitter with the hashtag
we want stargate and to just swamp
twitter with that we want images we want
fans talking about it we wanted to
absolutely ram down amazon's throat the
fact that we want this show and we love
it so much that we're willing to just go
to back for it and to make sure that
this check this show gets made but we
have to ask the question will it work
i think yes it will because amazon are
probably the
main company out of all of them that
love metadata more than anyone
they absolutely
thrive on surveys on ratings i always
felt netflix was chasing after um the
the plaudits they they wanted an oscar
you know they wanted awards but amazon
they're a company that all they want is
numbers they don't really care about
anything else other than the cha-ching
the money the dollar and that metadata
because that metadata is what leads them
to
finding more and more coin which is all
they really want
so for one yes i think it will work and
i think we've got some evidence to prove
that it does work if you go back and
look at the live video i talk about the
james bond example but there are others
this twitter storm idea has actually
been done before back in 2019 we
screened bring back stargate and it
actually came that close to it if you
remember
it was just after the twitter storm that
mgm did go to
brad wright and say write us a pilot
so let's look at the evidence
we know that amazon loves metadata we
can see that in the james bond example
recently how idris elba all of a sudden
has become the number one target again
and they've completely scrapped their
other plan that they do love metadata
and that's the way they're looking at we
know that they are considering the
stargate franchise and trying to figure
out what to do with it we know they have
a script from brad wright that mgm
ordered nearly three years ago and we
know that last time there was a twitter
storm it worked because mgm listened by
the way if you do like the content
please don't forget to like and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
you can also consider becoming a member
hit the join button that little bit of
contribution every month really helps us
to create more content
so
to support this i've designed a series
of t-shirts and cups and everything it's
a very simple design it's hashtag we
want stargate i have set this up so i
personally do not make any money off
this project it's not doing this for
profit what i'm doing though is that i
would love everybody to get on there buy
a t-shirt buy a mug buy a
pint glass whatever
take a photo of yourself wearing that
and then on the day on july 27th post
that with the hashtag we want stargate
now i'm told by people who know a bit
more about twitter than me that actually
an image
with the hashtag actually does push
things up the trending list more than
just the hashtag itself
so that's one of the reasons why i did
this but also i just think we need to
show amazon that we love this show and
that we are going to do whatever we need
to do to get it made
we want it and we want it now
we don't just want any old tv show
either we want brad wright to make this
show or at least brad right to run this
show and we want a good quality product
because stargate has always been quality
i honestly think we need to shove our
collective boots right up amazon's
backside and give them a collective kick
we need stargate to be back but we need
a quality stargate to be back because
sga sgu sg-1 they were all quality tv
shows this was not quantity over quality
ever with this franchise so we need a
good tv show hopefully brad wright would
be at the helm
i'm really hopeful that whoever they get
to run the show though loves it as much
as brad wright does because that's the
most important thing
in the comments guys tell me exactly
what you think is this a plan you can
get behind is this something that you
want to see
and will you join me live on july 27th
for our twitter storm show
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out and if you like
the content i produce please consider
showing me a bit more support and hit
the join button become a sidetracker or
a psi legend it really supports the
channel and you know
helps me to create more content
as always guys please stay safe and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you